[Musique]
je m'appelle j'y suis né j'y 11 ans et
je suis en studio mal j'adore voyager
car j'aime découvrir de nouvelles
cultures
ma plus grande passion et la danse celle
ci me permet de me surpasser de dépenser
mon énergie est d'abord y nommément de
plaisir lors de cette présentation
je vous en apprendrez davantage sur la
réalité virtuelle
une invention révolutionnaire encore
méconnue par plusieurs personnes
[Applaudissements]
attention parce qu'une invention
révolutionnaire fera bientôt un saut
dans toutes nos maisons
si ce n'est pas déjà fait et oui je l'aï
peut être déjà devenu c'est la réalité
virtuelle
lors de cette présentation je vous en
apprendrez davantage sur l'historique de
cette intervention sur son utilité est
finalement sur quelques conséquences que
cette invention à son autre monde
commençons avec l'historique pour la
réalité virtuelle
il y a deux appréciations weyer qui est
en anglais pour virtual violi hervé qui
est en français pour réalité virtuelle
tout a commencé dans les années 1950
quand la compagne martine et olic a
inventé le sens rahmane
le voici le sens rama est infiniment
individuel dans lesquels on présentait
cinq copines et c'était le premier
cinéma qui me présenter des films qui
exploite et quelques-uns de nos sens et
pour cela on avait intégré à cette
invention en sièges vibrants et un
ventilateur continuant avec le premier
casque de réalité virtuelle
il a été bon
en 1968 par yvan s'auto rennes le voit
si on surnommait aussi ses casques de
réalité virtuelle
l'épée de damoclès puisque les pays de
damoclès normale est très lourd et c'est
kas qui s'y étaient en effet très lourd
donc seulement gardons images on peut se
dire que le casse n'avait pas la très
portatif qu'esthétique n'était pas à son
meilleur et qu'il n'avait pas la très
efficace
voici maintenant à quoi ressemble au
casque de réalité virtuelle
ils sont beaucoup plus légers beaucoup
plus portative leur esthétique est
vraiment meilleur ils sont beaucoup plus
efficaces
je vous explique pourquoi donc pendant
très longtemps on a pu retrouver sur le
marché de la réalité virtuelle des
casques qui nous présentait un degré de
tendue dion de 110 degrés ce qui
équivaut à la moitié du décret
d'échantillons normal des humains
puisque celui ci est de 220 intègre
maintenant on est capable de retrouver
seul homme sur le marché des casques qui
nous présente un degré de champion de
200 à 210 décrit ce qui nous permet
vraiment une meilleure immersion dans le
film ou dans une situation qu'on est
dans la réalité virtuelle
continuons avec l'utilité de ce casque
donc ça peut être aussi d'éducation
donc ça peut être pour reprendre des
cours comme si on était dans la classe
leur sont les avez manqués ça peut être
un outil de formation donc ça peut être
des formations militaires au préparer
des militaires à toutes des choses qui
peuvent arriver pendant leur mission
donc ça va être quoi faire quand il ya
des explosions ou quoi fréquents et des
blessés puis aussi s'appelle
d'information médicale donc ça peut être
dans tous les domaines font partie de la
médecine
donc ça veut dire ça peut être autant
les chirurgiens que des ambulanciers
pour lui préparer à toute éventualité
que vers vie pendant les heures de
travail
donc ça peut être pratiqué l'art ca ou
encore coiffeur dans les blessures
particulière ça peut être aussi un outil
de touristes dont pour visiter des
endroits virtuellement v comme si on y
était pour de vrai ça peut être un outil
comme on le sait tous de divertissement
donc pour jouer à des jeux vidéo ou
encore pour pour écouter les films
sinon ça peut être un outil médical donc
ça peut être pour vaincre des folies
donc par exemple j'ai par des moteurs
des avions
il est prévu une simulation de vol comme
j'étais vraiment dans l'avion virtuel
puis comme je pourrais apprivoiser peu à
peu ma peur est finalement la voir aussi
la réalité virtuelle vous a vraiment
prouvé avec des recherches que ça peut
beaucoup à 10 par rapport à l'autisme
donc des autistes c'est des personnes
qui ont plus de difficultés avec le
social à s'intégrer aux autres donc on
préfère simplement pour un enfant
autiste du niveau primaire
on pourrait le mettre dans une situation
d'interaction sociale virtuelle comme
dans une discussion place où le
professeur ou un des élèves de classes
pourraient poser des questions à
l'enfant autiste et c'est vraiment
prouvé ça aide beaucoup les personnes
autistes à mieux comprendre et à mieux
interpréter le monde qui les entoure
donc maintenant les conséquences de
cette invention sur l'autre mans land
est positif et de négatif
les pousse t c'est plutôt les meilleurs
d'utiliser la réalité virtuelle comme je
vous l'aï dit précédemment mais on a
aussi des négatifs que je vais vous dire
dont bien sûr les casques de réalité
virtuelle
ils sont fabriqués dans des usines et
les gaziers des usines polluent la
planète
mais il ya aussi des usines ou magasins
de vente et des magasins vente à nos
maisons il ya eu énormément de moyens de
transport sont utilisés qui eux aussi
polluent énormément la planète si aussi
par rapport à la désensibilisation de
l'individu dont par exemple - chaque
jour je vois des jeux sans m'arrêter
plein d'or prouve par force le plus de
personnes possible de monter il s'agit
dans le mental parce que la réalité
virtuelle saadi dans non s'il virtuel
qui ressent énormément la réalité donc
on m'en donnait mon cerveau c'est tout
d'abord ce puissant mais lève mon
empathie ma compassion doute les
sentiments qui m'empêcherait de
commettre un geste comme sonore est vu
comme un meurtre n'ont reçu je pourrais
le faire dans la vraie vie
puis ça ferait plus rien donc faut
vraiment faire attention à ce maintenant
j'ai une proposition pour les ingénieurs
de réalité virtuelle d'un modèle de
casque
donc pour moi le casse parfait ça serait
un casque qui serait fait le plus
possible de matériaux réutilisés donc du
verre du plastique du bois aussi il y
aurait 1 min à fait intégrés à ce modèle
de casque là pour bien sûr limité temps
d'utilisation pour peut être le cas de
la désensibilisation de l'individu
survient il y aurait aussi possibilité
de contrôle parental pour que les
parents d'enfants possédant un casque de
réalité virtuelle puisque ne peut
contrôler ce que leurs enfants font sur
le casque pour qu'ils jouent à des jeux
appropriés pour son âge
mais pour les personnes dans la salle
pétriz peut-être la réalité virtuelle
mais qui ont pas vraiment de supervision
comme ça peut être dix adolescents ou
encore des adultes vient je vous suggère
vraiment de faire attention à ce que
vous faites avec la réalité virtuelle
mais aussi a toujours pensé que les
choses dans le virtuel qu'on peut pas
avoir que sont la réalité
comment manger boire dormir aller jouer
dehors
avoir des amis dont il faut toujours
bien pensé à ce donc pour conclure oui
la réalité virtuelle
c'est vraiment une invention qui
révolutionnèrent mais se sait pour des
bonnes et des moins bonnes raisons tout
ce qu'il faut savoir s'il faut savoir
rester dans le moment présent il faut
savoir différencie le virtuel de la
réalité il faut savoir bien utiliser la
réalité virtuelle et finalement d'oser
être utilisation merci et bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]